well the nhl is getting really close to
a return to play and fans at least
can see the light at the end of the
tunnel and according to various reports
the nhl will open its season january
13th
with a 56-game season there will be a
10-day training camp no exhibition games
for golden knights fans that's terrific
news what's not terrific though the part
of the business
to free up cap space tsn reporting the
knights are shopping max patch are ready
i'm told that the vegas golden knights
have doubled down in recent days and
weeks in an attempt to try and move
max pats ready he's got three years left
at seven million dollars a year coming
off of a 32 goal
shortened season and you think back
previous
in this offseason they were trying to
move any number of players on their team
to try and gain salary cap flexibility
there's no question
the team is over the cap at this point
they believe they can be cap compliant
by
opening night but pacharetti would go a
long way in terms of getting some of
that flexibility
and also enable them to potentially take
a run at any number of the high profile
free agents
that remains unsigned at this point like
a mike hoffman or an eric halla
all right now tomorrow we're going to
find out more about what's going on with
the vegas gold knights when we visit
with owner bill foley we got a ton of
questions about the team this season
and what about fans at the building this
year that's coming up tomorrow
right here on channel 8.